und abzocke ist ein gutes thema das ist
auch heute das thema für meine fünf
tipps und das sind wirklich unglaubliche
sachen deswegen sind diese tipps ganz
ganz wichtig es geht nämlich darum wie
ist es mit unseriösen handwerkern und
haustürgeschäften seriöse handwerker
würden niemals so arbeiten schauen sie
mir wir waren beide nachbarn haben
gesehen bei ihnen auf dem dach sind auch
einige ziegel locker wir schauen uns das
mal eben kurz an und das kostet sie auch
alles nicht absolute vorsicht deswegen
hier meine fünf tipps stehen plötzlich
unangemeldet handwerker vor ihrer tür
seien sie erst mal total skeptisch
lassen sie sich nicht in ein gespräch
verwickeln unterschreiben sie nichts
machen sie einfach die tür zu es gibt
sonst nur ärger tipp 2
besondere vorsicht bei so dach und
pflasterarbeiten die masche ist halt so
da werden einfach mal bei ihnen auf dem
dach ein paar ziegel entfernt und am
ende haben sie dann noch und müssen dann
irgendwas machen also ganz ganz
vorsichtig bei handwerkern die dach- und
pflasterarbeiten ausführen
tipp 3 haustürgeschäfte sind generell
keine schnäppchen da hat niemand etwas
zu verschenken und achtung auch teppiche
besteck schmuck und andere leistungen
sind oft wirklich sehr gering wertig und
machen wirklich nur ärger tipp 4 wenn
sie schon was unterschrieben haben
nutzen sie wirklich ihr widerrufsrecht
sie haben 14 tage die möglichkeit zu
widerrufen und wieder rufen sie am
besten schriftlich per einschreiben an
die adresse die auf dem vertrag
angegeben ist und tipp 5 wenn wirklich
gar nichts anderes hilft und sie fühlen
sich wirklich total überrumpelt und
ausgenutzt dann schalten sie auf jeden
fall die polizei an und stellen sie dann
strafanzeige